Fire And Blood will reign again and you can
expect to see the Robert's Rebellion in the
later
and final seasons of House of the Dragon!
The upcoming Game of Thrones prequel series,
House of the Dragon, is based on the George
RR Martin's Targaryen history book Fire & Blood.
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
In other words it covers events from Aegon's
Conquest to the Dance of the Dragons.
That's Fire And Blood volume 1.
House of the Dragon will start with a build
up towards the Dance of the Dragons and early
seasons will cover the Dance itself. Later
seasons however, will be based on George RR
Martin’s yet unfinished Fire And Blood volume
2 book .
The yet unreleased Fire And Blood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
How do I know the second part of the Targaryen
history will cover all that? Because George
RR Martin himself revealed it.
Fire And Blood volume 1 has 700 pages.
In comparison, the book material Game of Thrones
show used was 4000 pages with the additional
summary from George RR Martin about the ending.
This prequel will last at least as long as
Game of Thrones and to achieve that, the showrunners
will use Fire And Blood volume 2 material
and as I already said, the main events of
it are the Blackfyre Rebellions and the Robert's
Rebellion so this is something you will see
on screen in the later seasons of House of
the Dragon.
Robert's Rebellion,also known as the War of
the Usurper, was a rebellion against House
Targaryen, primarily instigated by Eddard
Stark, Jon Arryn, and Robert Baratheon, for
whom it's named.
It lasted "close to a year" and resulted with
the end of the Targaryen dynasty in the Seven
Kingdoms
and the beginning of Robert Baratheon's reign.
It had 10 major battles and ultimately resulted
with the victory for the rebels, the end of
the Targaryen dynasty, and the start of the
Baratheon dynasty.
In the prelude to the rebellion we have Tourney
at Harrenhal. After winning the final tilt,
Prince Rhaegar Targaryen was to crown the
new queen of love and beauty. Instead of crowning
his wife, the Dornish princess Elia Martell,
Rhaegar rode past her and crowned Lyanna Stark
of Winterfell instead who was bethroted to
Robert Baratheon. Eddard Stark would later
recall this moment as "the moment when all
smiles died". At the coming of the near year,
the Starks received a message of Lyanna Stark's
abduction by Prince Rhaegar Targaryen near
Harrenhal. Her brother, Brandon Stark, was
on his way to Riverrun to wed Catelyn Tully,
when the news reached him. Brandon rode at
once to King's Landing with his companions.
Brandon rode for the Red Keep, and outside
its gates, unaware that Rhaegar was not present,
shouted for him to come out and die. King
Aerys II had them all arrested for plotting
the murder of the crown prince, and summoned
the fathers of all those who stood accused
to court. Lord Rickard Stark, who had been
on his way south with the wedding party for
Brandon's wedding, went to King's Landing
with two hundred men. None of them returned
north. In King's Landing, all of those who
stood accused were executed, with the sole
exception of Ethan Glover. King Aerys did
allow for trials, of a sort. Lord Rickard
Stark demanded a trial by battle, and the
king granted his request.
Rickard dressed for battle, but Aerys declared
fire to be the champion of House Targaryen.
He had Rickard suspended from the rafters
in the throne room, where his pyromancers,
kindled a blaze beneath the Lord of Winterfell.
Brandon Stark was brought in as well, and
placed in a Tyroshi strangling device, while
a longsword was placed just outside his reach.
Brandon was allowed to try and free his father,
but more he struggled to reach the sword,
the tighter the cord around his neck became.
Brandon strangled himself in an attempt to
reach the sword and save his father, while
Lord Rickard cooked in his armor. Next, Aerys
demanded that Lord Jon Arryn sends him the
heads of Lord Robert Baratheon of Storm's
End, Lyanna's betrothed, and Eddard Stark,
now the Lord of Winterfell after the deaths
of his father and older brother. Robert and
Eddard were Jon's wards at the Eyrie however,
and Jon instead raised his banners in revolt.
This act is seen as the start of the war,
which would last "close to a year". Not all
the lords in the Vale had sided with Jon Arryn,
and not all the lords in the stormlands sided
with Robert Baratheon. Robert himself firstly
defeated those who sided with King Aerys in
the Vale and then fought and won 3 battles
in 1 day in the stormlands against those who
sided with King Aerys there. The next major
battle was the Battle of Ashford where Robert
Baratheon was defeated by Randyll Tarly which
was the only defeat for Robert in the entire
war. Robert managed to escape capture with
the bulk of his forces.
Following the battle, Mace Tyrell marched
on Storm's End and laid siege to the castle.
Eddard Stark had managed to reach Winterfell,
where he called his banners. He marched south
with his forces, and joined up with Lord Jon
Arryn. Together, they negotiated with Lord
Hoster Tully, the Lord of Riverrun for support.
Meanwhile Hand of the King to the Mad King,
Jon Connington, led a mighty army into the
field. The forces he commanded gave chase,
and Robert's march became a grueling one.
Robert, wounded through unknown means, and
all alone, eventually took refuge at Stoney
Sept,
which would become the site of our next battle,
the Battle of the Bells. Jon Connington's
forces took the town by force and began to
search every house. The residents of the town
were actively helping Robert however, and
despite the search, then offered pardons,
rewards and threats, they could not find Robert.
The battle began when Lords Stark and Tully
arrived with a rebel army. The soldiers fought
in the streets and alleys and on rooftops,
and septons rang the bells to warn the residents
to lock their doors. The battle was fierce,
and Jon Connington managed to wound Hoster
Tully and kill Jon Arryn's cousin, Ser Denys
Arryn. Eventually, Robert Baratheon came out
of the Peach, the brothel in which he had
been hiding, and fought with Connington, almost
killing him. With both Elbert Arryn and Denys
Arryn now dead, Jon Arryn was in need of an
heir. Hoster Tully swiftly betrothed his daughter,
Lysa, to Jon. In a double ceremony at Riverrun,
Eddard Stark and Jon Arryn married Hoster's
daughters, Catelyn and Lysa, respectively.
The crown prince finally returned from the
south and convinced Aerys to ask Tywin Lannister
for help, just as the rebels had or would
do, at one point. Additionally, Aerys commanded
his alchemists to place caches of wildfire
on multiple locations in King's Landing. After
at first refusing to send aid to Aerys, both
due to his caution as well as due to his anger
over Elia's treatment,
Prince Doran Martell agreed to send ten thousand
Dornishmen to strengthen the army Prince Rhaegar
Targaryen was gathering. The Battle of the
Trident was the next and decisive battle in
the war. Fought in 283 AC between the loyalist
and rebels, the battle took place at a place
known as the ruby ford since the battle, located
on the northern bank of the Trident, where
Rhaegar tried to cross the river. The loyalists
had forty thousand men, while the army of
the rebels numbered less men, who were more
battle hardened. Rhaegar and Lord Robert Baratheon
met in single combat with the battle raging
on all around them. Rhaegar managed to wound
Robert before Robert killed Rhaegar with a
blow to the chest from his warhammer. Eventually,
the Targaryen host broke and ran. Around the
time the Battle of the Trident was fought,
Robert proclaimed his intention to claim the
Iron Throne. Out of all three leaders of the
rebellion, Robert had the better claim, due
to the fact that his grandmother had been
Princess Rhaelle Targaryen, the youngest daughter
of King Aegon V Targaryen. To justify Robert's
claim, the maesters would later use his bloodties
to House Targaryen, although it was conquest
which won him the throne.
Already prior to the Battle of the Trident,
King Aerys had been preparing his wildfire
plot. Aerys sent his wife, Queen Rhaella pregnant
with Daenerys along with his new heir, Prince
Viserys, to Dragonstone for safety. While
the Trident is seen by many as the decisive
battle of the war, the capital remained untaken
until the Sack of King's Landing when Tywin
Lannister showed up at capital to finish the
rebellion
when Aerys hoped Tywin would help him. Upon
realization that all was lost, Aerys ordered
Rossart to ignite the wildfire caches throughout
the city, wishing to leave Robert nothing
but “ashes and bones”. He ordered Ser
Jaime Lannister, Lord Tywin’s eldest son,
to kill Tywin and bring his head to Aerys.
Instead, Jaime killed Rossart, and upon realization
that Aerys would simply give the order to
burn the city down to another pyromancer,
returned to the Red Keep and killed Aerys
himself in the throne room while Tywin's men
killed Rhaegar's wife and children. Robert
was pleased by these deaths, but Eddard was
furious. This resulted in an argument between
Eddard and Robert, and Eddard rode out alone
in anger to fight the final battles of the
war in the south. After lifting the siege
at Storm's End, Lord Eddard Stark rode further
south, to the tower of joy, and after battling
the legendary kingsguard, he found his sister
Lyanna dying after giving birth to Rhaegar's
child. The final battle of the war was assault
on Dragonstone where the last Targaryens were.
Rhaella died giving birth to Princess Daenerys
Targaryen during a great storm that destroyed
the Targaryen fleet at anchor at the island.
With most of the Targaryen fleet destroyed,
and with the Baratheon fleet ready to take
Dragonstone, the household of the last Targaryen
stronghold was willing to sell the children
to the new king, Robert I Baratheon. Shortly
before Stannis sailed to Dragonstone, however,
Willem Darry and four loyal men smuggled Viserys,
Daenerys, and her wet nurse from the nursery
and sailed for the Braavosian coast, and the
children subsequently lived in exile in the
Free Cities. Following the conclusion of the
rebellion, Robert I Baratheon was successfully
installed as the new Lord of the Seven Kingdoms.
Robert named his foster father, Jon Arryn,
as his Hand of the King. Robert had no wish
to marry following the death of his betrothed,
Lyanna Stark, but Jon convinced him to marry
Lord Tywin Lannister's daughter, Cersei,
as the marriage would ensure Tywin's support,
should Viserys Targaryen ever attempt to win
his throne back. That's the story of the Robert's
Rebellion.
Thank you so much for watching, hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did make sure to give
it a big thumbs up and I hope to see you in
the next one, peace!